on peut pas instrumentaliser une mairie
on peut lancer un mouvement comme le dit
Laurent nemane de solidarité c'est très
bien d'être fidèle à ses idées mais on
peut pas instrumentaliser une mairie et
ses services en fermant une mairie comme
ça de façon unilatérale ça a pas de sens
surtout ce qui est le plus drôle venant
de Anne Hidalgo ils sont le PS est en
opposition avec toutes les réformes de
retraite depuis Balladur woerthe et puis
quand ils sont au pouvoir et notamment
la loi Touraine ils ont fait plus encore
ils font d'assuranchir donc dans
l'opposition il manifeste il ferme des
mairies et quand ils sont au pouvoir ils
ont bien conscience de la réalité des
choses il les régimes de retraite
aujourd'hui sont déficitaires donc il
faut d'abord rétablir l'équilibre moi je
ne veux pas que mes enfants payent la
retraite c'est une dette qu'on laisse
aux enfants payent la retraite ma
retraite à moi encore plus aujourd'hui
c'est 30 milliards
répartition le fait que
votre retraite c'est-à-dire la
génération active des retraités donc
vous êtes contre le système par la
partie aujourd'hui ce régime est
déficitaire de 30 aujourd'hui
déficit des 10 prochaines années mais
pas d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on crée
une dette de 30 milliards par an plus 5
milliards sur les régimes spéciaux et ça
c'est de l'argent qui manque au budget
de l'État pour des hôpitaux pour la
transition écologique pour donc il faut
équilibrer ça c'est la première chose et
le PS le voit bien quand il est au
pouvoir il voit bien qu'il faut aller
plus loin et travailler un petit peu
plus après la question et celle de la
Justice de la réforme je dis ça depuis
le début c'est très il est nécessaire de
travailler plus mais on va rentrer dans
le vif du sujet répartis et c'est ça la
vraie question moi quand je suis salarié
de d'une entreprise je ne suis pas
propriétaire de ces actifs je ne peux
pas faire ça c'est chacun travail dans
un environnement on peut pas utiliser
les actifs qui ne sont pas les siens
pour faire pression après bon on a
l'habitude de se rendre pression mais je
n'ai pas vu de réformes de retraite qui
qui se passent enfin de la femme qui se
passe facilement c'est évident quand
vous devez allonger le temps de travail
que personne ne réagit favorablement
c'est la responsabilité aujourd'hui
politique de le faire comme je l'ai dit
pour équilibrer les comptes des 30
milliards qui dépend que l'État dépense
chaque année pour les retraites cet
argent qu'on a pas qu'on emprunte sur
les marchés et donc c'est de la dette ça
c'est la responsabilité politique la
deuxième responsabilité et moi je me
réjouis que le débat se déroule à
l'Assemblée c'est la justice d'une ou la
justesse et la justice d'une réforme et
je vais pouvoir remarquer que l'entre le
début décembre et aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus du tout la même loi on est plus sur
les 65 ans et sur 64 en deux temps 63
jusqu'en 2027 et ensuite 64 ans et puis
d'une très nombreuses mesures
d'accompagnement vous avez 40% des
personnes qui ne partiront pas à 64 ans
donc ces mesures sont beaucoup plus
jusqu'à ne l'étaient au départ et c'est
ça qu'il faut améliorer encore au
Parlement et à la fin du débat la loi va
encore beaucoup évoluer notamment sur
les phares par exemple ce sujet a été vu
identifié il y a 48 heures et bien
forcément il va être amélioré à
l'Assemblée et ce sujet qui est très
grave très important et pense que
l'assemblée va le résoudre dans les
débats parlementaires en tout cas le
modèle à deux amendements très précis
pour rééquilibrer justement le départ
des femmes avec celui des hommes sinon
au Parlement il va y avoir 73 heures de
débats sur cette réforme la réforme
Touraine avait généré 45 heures de débat
la réforme verte un peu plus de 60
ans
la réforme verte est passée de 60 à 62
le PS c'était opposé et aujourd'hui la
demande c'est 62 ans
les milliardaires aujourd'hui grâce à la
politique fiscale que l'on a mené vous
avez 10% de chômeurs en moins en 2022
pour réduisez les droits des chômeurs
c'est facile de faire baisser le nombre
bon
on est au terme de
qualité ne développements économique
c'est l'emploi des seniors qui a
augmenté de de 10%, etc donc on a des
réalités qui vont peser sur les comptes
publics et qui vont permettre peut-être
en 2027 sur le livret des comptes merci
tous les jours madame